What I want to show you now is a development
of that.
Which you may well have read about.
I'm not sure whether James Bond used one
but certainly it's one of the favourite weapons
in current espionage stories.
And that is, what we call, the laser eavesdropper.
A device by which it is possible, under good
conditions,
to hear what is going on in a room
when you've not been able to put a microphone
inside it.
So you've got to work entirely from outside.
And this diagram will give you an idea of
what it is.
There we have a laser.
Pointing in the direction of that little house.
And it goes through the window.
You can work off the window but it's better
to go inside,
and here is a picture frame.
And much exaggerated - the picture frame will
vibrate like that.
In sympathy with any vibrations that fall
on it from people talking in the room.
If you can pick up a reflection off the glass
of the picture frame,
as it bends like that it will move the beam
coming back.
And we now have an optical lever,
equal in length from there, right across to
there.
And it will swing about. It's a tiny amount
of course.
Less than a micron certainly, here.
From one photo cell to the other, and that
will generate currents
of the same frequency as the vibration in
the picture frame.
And so now if we switch on the...
We'll pretend here that there is a radio going
in the house
and we will listen to... [Music plays on radio]
Now you'll just be able to, if you're near,
to hear this, but... [Music gets quieter]
Now.
OK.
[Music comes on loudly from device.] Yes.
[Music cuts out]
Actually, I think we're listening to New Zealand
[Music is audible again]
And [Music is silenced] all that sound is
coming along the beam of light.
[Music resumes]
[Man sings: Tuhituhi taku reta]
[Audience laughs]
[Man sings: tuku atu taku rīng]
Must let him do that bit again, musn't we?
[Man sings: Whati whati taku pene]
[Applause]